welcome to this video playing Johan song
yeah that's a strange account I had him
had him before yeah it says it's got no
title Kyle Frederick johansson he has a
huge rating yeah but nobody knows who
that is and it's not that okay so let's
see this is a non rated player I mean no
feeder yellow and you don't have to six
without a feeder writing so let's see
hmm the touch again okay I can't I can't
do this see something c5 based again
maybe this one then some old bean only
stuff
I am interesting so yeah f5 f5 probably
trying to make use that the night is not
yet on f6 of course white can play with
afore and try to play for the light
squares yeah exactly but not much to do
about it the nature of this position so
let's trade them so okay it's clear that
you will get the point back at some
point i think but i will so try to make
it a bit more difficult simply because
this some also it develops a piece that
make some sense okay
yeah g4 and 93 is the way to go and
probably slightly better for what
I by the way don't get me wrong I don't
think that this is a computer right it's
just that it's not the person that is
mentioned in the account this is your
handsome guy I really think it's
impossible to get to this kind of rating
without having any kind of feeder rating
so let's so let's see i'd like to get my
my bishop traded maybe its back-end
Bishop g5
f form comes in 20 interesting
sacrificing a pawn okay I'm taking that
and I don't think you can avoid that
porn anyway so make sure tix make sure
that the dark squared bishop is leaving
the board
hmm I don't really believe in that pawn
sacrifice my light squares are a bit
sensitive but the bishop is really on g2
it's not like 1g six or something even
then it wasn't wouldn't be so clear and
so Jake's
I just win their porn for nothing really
for nothing
like even has the better King position
getting look at five Andrew gave aid
Jeff that looks really nice the only
thing missing from the this pictures my
night somehow playing Knight f6 or
something okay I can also do this just
take f2 yeah maybe let's do that I'm
pretty I'm pretty much ad on the clock
King g1 is the only move to to cover it
really night up to g6 is a good plan
Bishop b4 i have quicker route g5 don't
mind that i can just take that right
you six is covered
how to play night Jason I'll a g6 I can
actually do that I mean this Bishop
Issus is pinned yeah not bad
night f4 is pretty strong once it hits
that's just one moment no don't need you
happy fancy him
I just simple and I to AFF one this is
ending the whole thing yeah yeah I can
take on f2 just not totally sure if it
wins easily I mean check there yes a
couple of checks he has a couple of
checks there
now come on let's let's play it play
technically that chance just just easy
and without any risk
got material and strategic advantage
here so I didn't feel it's necessary to
risk anything there Knight takes from 95
95 and yeah I guess maybe flavor
the kia new gas to blonde should be okay
and he took my hope white resigns hmm
yeah that was a surprisingly clear
victory then I'd f5 was a surprising
pawn sacrifice really okay 97's is just
saying okay I know that didn't help much
but Bishop g5 is my idea and I don't
believe in that move I simply don't wear
a as White's compensation no it's bishop
there this would be the piece that is
activated on the light squares to
justify compensation from apartment it's
simply not active and yeah I'm getting
that porn and there was really no
compensation can only argue i probably
could have won quicker but i thought i
would get to of course i can take on f2e
already but I was just I was just too
too focused on yeah being being solid
let's say yeah here maybe I can take
chance yeah but I wasn't totally sure if
he has some kind of play here I don't
know check check but I have g60 kfj six
Kim okay then that was simpler but that
the [ __ ] game is just a total win
without any problems Black has 22 pounds
by now and and just a better position
his pawn structure is perfect and white
has the bad bishop so it's a very simple
win so no I'm no big difference really
to the other thing a win is a win yeah
this this opening here so it's not that
bad c4 is a bit surprising normally why
players avoid the c-4 move if black is
committed to that and they quite often
play em play like that so that they have
helped this check for example available
and have an active
shove their on everyone um of course
what he played is not bad but it's it's
lesson it's less common jinx yeah this
is actually interesting I was thinking
about it briefly but I wasn't sure if
it's worth it yeah actually preventing
just g-form but of course h5 is a move
that weakens very much long-term so I
wasn't totally sold on this is a good
idea ok well thanks for watching